- Women should be paid
twice as much as men.
- Shut up, libtard.
- Go away, loser.
- I am drinking
your liberal tears.
- Stop.
Are you sick and tired
of trolls ruining
your social media experience?
- Yes.
- Well then the Troll
Cliche Wiki is for you.
When a troll attacks
with an insult
you've heard a
thousand times before.
- Triggered much?
Delete your account, bitch.
- Don't waste your
time arguing with him.
Just head on over
to trollcliches.com.
Find the cliche that your
troll's been engaging in.
Copy and paste that hot URL
and then send him the link.
- What?
- It's that easy?
- It's that easy.
- Shut the fuck up, snowflake.
- But what if the
troll keeps responding?
- Well, I wish I thought
of that possibility.
I did.
Now you just send
him a second URL.
One that says you've
already lost this argument.
Just keep sending him the link
again and again and again.
- Again?
No.
- [Man With Glasses] And again.
- I'm not fucking triggered.
(groaning)
- Your gender gives
you a lower IQ.
(laughing)
- [Man With Glasses] And again.
- Make these stop.
- So fun.
- I can't can't can't can't.
- And eventually ...
They'll go away for good.
- Very cool.
- Very cool indeed.
Trollcliches.com
Try it today.
(laughing)